that breaks my heart knowing that that i
was
doing all this stuff and i was making
all this content wow there was
people that were still really hurt by
what i made that's david dobrik tearing
up
posting a second apology video in the
wake of sexual misconduct allegations
surrounding the vlog squad i think with
this situation there's a lot i can look
at and there's a lot i can learn from
but there's a lot of mistakes that i
made
and i'm sorry for that i'm sorry for
everybody i've let down
i'm sorry to my family and i'm sorry to
my friends that i'm embarrassed
and that this won't happen again last
week dobrik posted a video
apologizing to joseph seth francois
following his allegation of sexual
misconduct in a 2017
prank video i wanted to come out and say
something
to clear my own conscience from the
things that i was doing
and i was allowing to happen within
david's content
francois says he was tricked into
kissing jason
nash this is also david's content and
he's the one that's coming up with the
ideas and he's the one that has the
power and is asking people
to participate in certain things and
there is a lot of pressure
you know when you're in the room and
you're the only person of your skin
color or your culture
and you're trying to represent in the
right way and you're constantly being
pressured
to do things that you might know are
wrong and you are uncomfortable with
the set situation i'm sorry to seth
because
i like i said i i just want to make
videos
where everybody in it you know whether
you're participating or watching
is enjoying and having a good time and i
miss the mark with that one
and i'm really sorry i truly truly am
dobrik also said in the video that he's
no longer friends with dom zeglitis
aka dirty dom and doesn't stand for any
misconduct after a woman came forward
alleging zeglitis sexually assaulted her
when she came to the vlog squad's home
to film a video in 2018.
e.t has reached out to zeg lydis for
comment
the main reason i'm making this video is
to hold accountability for my actions
and
you know not only not only apologize to
you know people that i worked with that
i may have disrespected
but also to other people that were
affected by my actions
i've been really disappointed by some of
my friends and for that reason
i've separated from a lot of them
following the allegations
against the blog squad several brands
have come forward
saying they're dropping their
partnerships with dobrik and
late monday night dobrick posted a
second video
admitting his first apology video missed
the mark
i put myself in a lot of situations
where i needed to apologize for my past
actions and i've never done this
correctly and i've never done this
respectfully
and my last video is a testament to that
i i don't want to
defend that video i don't want to delete
that video dobrick said that the biggest
mistake he made
was never apologizing to the women who
claim zeglitis
sexually assaulted them what i didn't do
is i didn't go back to any of these
women
and apologize i i kind of moved on
and i learned from it and i grew from it
but i
didn't address the situation with these
women i'm not talking publicly i'm
saying even privately i didn't reach out
to any of these people
and that breaks my heart knowing that
that i was
doing all this stuff and i was making
all this content while there was people
that were still really hurt
by what i made and while the content
creator acknowledged the many fans
coming forward in his defense
he said he doesn't want the support he
wants to course correct
it was cowardly of me to say in my last
apology that i missed the mark
because it's gross and i'm sorry a lot
of people reached out to me saying
cancer culture is [ __ ] you need to
fight back and you need to call people
out and i don't agree with how this
should be taken
at all and i think when there is a
crisis there's a serious opportunity
to correct yourself to learn and improve
and to make sure those mistakes
don't happen again and that's what is so
important to hold yourself accountable
now dobrick says he's going to take a
little time off to reflect
grow and figure out how to do better i
might take a short break from all the
social media stuff because i realize
there's a serious lack of infrastructure
when i make any kind of content and i
want to be able to have
a place of checks and balances i want to
have hr and i want to be able
um to have people communicate discomfort
in a way that's
that's comfortable to them and where
they don't feel
like their emotions or what they're
doing or
or how their acting is compromised
you